listed in the top 62 from the 500 most
influential Muslims of the world the
only Muslim preacher oror amongst the
100 most powerful Indians
internationally most sought after oror
on Islam and comparative religion Dr Zak
nayum and now he's coming to Malaysia
I'll be coming to Malaysia after 11
years the Malaysia tour 2012 a 4-day
public talk and an open question answer
session by Dr Zakir Nik Muhammad s.
wasam in world's religious scriptures
inshallah Friday 28th September 2012
8:00 p.m. at dataran bandaraya johu baru
Without
You Universal Brotherhood inshallah on
Saturday 29th September 2012 6:30 p.m.
at uitm Shah Alam every human being has
the knowledge of God in him the Quran
and modern science inshallah Friday 5th
October 2012 6:30 p.m. at D Jubilee
peranan there's no other scripture on
the face of the Earth which says marry
only one besides the Quran Islam's view
on terrorism and Jihad inshallah Sunday
7th October 2012 6:30 p.m. at Danton Rak
satu pwtc quala Lampur Islam is for
those who are spiritually high wish him
salad daang as he captivates and
educates people from all walks of life
with his enlightening public talk and an
engaging open questions and answers
session this is the best Global
salutation of Peace assalamu alaykum may
peace be on you feel proud to be an
integral part of this enthusiastic human
congregation to improve and increase
your awareness about Islam so lock your
calendars and be a part of his Malaysia
t
inshallah 28th and 29th September 2012
and on 5th and 7th October you can watch
him deliver the message of Peace free
entrance to all all Fates are welcome
special seating for ladies for
registration log on to Dr Zaki Nik
Malaysia tour
2012.
eventbrite.com or you can log on to
facebook.com/ Dr Zak Nik Malaysia toward
2012 be there to spread the message of
Peace inshallah hoping to see you there
the Malaysia tour